how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and all things relating to the
MCU
now although phase four got pushed back
due to the corona virus that doesn't
mean that Marvel Studios hasn't been
working this whole entire time in fact
they've been working in editing remotely
for pretty much the entire time that the
projects were put to a halt and this
whole entire time that Marvel Studios
was still working leaks have been coming
out and we've talked about a lot of
those leaks on my channel including
characters that have been confirmed or
rumored to be coming to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and phase four phase
5 and beyond but there are actually a
lot of characters new characters that
are coming to the MCU in phase four so
in this video we're going to go over
every single new character coming to
phase four both confirmed and rumored so
if you enjoy Marvel and the MCU be sure
to subscribe so you can stay up to date
on everything happening also so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a Wolverine Funko pop all you
have to do to enter subscribe to my
channel like this video and leave a
comment about the video down below so
there are already a ton of characters
that are confirmed for phase four
characters that we already know like red
guardian Alaina Bulova Black Knight of
the eternal so we're going to go over
those characters relatively quickly so
we can get to the main characters like
Nova and Namor and a lot of other
awesome characters so we'll start it off
with Black Widow the first movie that is
supposed to be coming to us in phase
four obviously Natasha is returning for
this Black Widow film but she's bringing
with her her family Yelena Bulova her
sister of the Red Room and another Black
Widow Alexei szostak ah've aka red
Guardian aka the Captain America of
Russia and Melina vasta cough who is
also iron maiden from the comics and we
also saw a glimpse at her iron maiden
mask in one of the trailers for Black
Widow and then of course she is going to
be bringing a villain with her
taskmaster the villain who can copy and
execute an opponent's skills and
fighting just by looking at them which
is why we see him rocking a shield
having claws like black panther and
moving like spider-man sometimes and
then we have the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier we know that US agent John
Walker is going to be making his MCU
debut
the new Captain America but sadly he's
going to actually be controlled by
Thunderbolt Ross who is expected to be
Red Hulk in this show and then we have a
really big rumor that Wolverine could
possibly show up or be teased in the
show as well we have seen leaked photos
of a logo on the back of a biker gangs
jacket that looks an awful lot like
Wolverines villain ogen and then we move
on to the Eternals in which all of the
cast is pretty much new to the MCU every
main character including the Eternals
the deviants and black knight will be
new to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
most of the Eternals have one or two
specific abilities that are very special
and unique to them but they all share a
group of abilities including superhuman
strength speed agility and they're
basically immortal and as far as Black
Knight is concerned he has a little bit
of magical abilities but is an expert
swordsman and the fact that he can keep
up with Captain America and even
Wolverine and then we have shang-chi and
the legend of the ten rings and this is
really exciting because some mutants are
reported to be in this film of course
shang-chi himself is an exciting and new
character coming to the MCU and we also
have the real and true Mandarin coming
not the Mandarin from Iron Man 3 he was
fake but besides shang-chi actually
entering the MCU the biggest thing about
this film is that there are rumors that
Omega Red and possibly Psylocke are
going to be making their debut in this
film as well we know that in the film
there's going to be a tournament to
compete for the 10 rings and apparently
in that tournament there's going to be
quite a handful of mutants and psylocke
and Omega Red are rumored to be two of
them and then we have quite possibly the
biggest film of phase 4 Doctor Strange
to Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness now truly the possibilities for
this film are limitless you have Doctor
Strange who can explore different
realities and different dimensions plus
we have the multiverse opening up as
well and there are just so many
characters that Marvel could easily put
into this film it's been confirmed that
Mordo is going to be returning he has
his unfinished business to deal with
from Doctor Strange 1 but then we have
some really big rumors one of which
being that Mephisto could be in Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness we
know that multiverse of madness is going
to be somewhat of a horror film
and that it's going to deal with some
demons and what better character to have
than a demon from Hell himself
Mephisto and speaking of characters who
are connected to hell Ghost Rider is
apparently supposed to make a debut and
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness as well connecting with both the
Mystics side and the demonic side of the
film and to top it all off we even have
a report from Mikey Sutton that Doctor
Strange is going to form the Illuminati
and Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness and depending on which direction
Marvel would want to go in this would
introduce several new characters the
original lineup including Iron Man who
of course won't be in the film because
Iron Man has gone for some time now
Doctor Strange of course Black Bolt the
king of the Inhumans namor the
sub-mariner Professor Xavier of the
x-men and mr. fantastic of the Fantastic
Four so if the Illuminati is introduced
and Marvel sticks true even just a
little bit to this original Illuminati
lineup we could be getting Professor
Xavier mr. fantastic and Namor I don't
however think that they'll bring the
Inhumans in and let's not forget that
before the director changed for the film
the old director and the previous
writers have said that nightmare is
supposed to be the main villain of this
film but we'll have to wait and see then
we have the Wanda vision series who are
going to bring in a few new characters
that are confirmed as well and some
rumored we know that Agatha Harkness is
going to be in the 1 division series
she is a Salem witch who has played a
very big role in the Marvel Comics
universe taking care of Wanda helping
her develop her powers and also taking
care of Franklin Richards the son of Sue
Storm aka the Invisible Woman and Reed
Richards mr. fantastic and she's going
to be played by Kathryn Hahn in the
series and thanks to a leaked audition
tape for the one division series we
seemingly know that Quicksilver is going
to be making his return but whether or
not that is permanent we'll have to wait
and see and much like with Doctor
Strange Mephisto is rumored to be in
this series as well and then we have the
Loki series which is going to have a lot
bigger impact to the MCU than people
actually think we already know and it's
confirmed that Loki is going to
introduce the TVA the time variant
authority and their job is to literally
monitor different timelines
in different universes to make sure
they're not threatening the other ones
when one of the universes or somebody
from one of the universes is threatening
another timeline or universe their job
is to destroy it but it's been reported
by a couple of different insiders that
Kang the Conqueror is going to make his
MCU debut in the Loki series which makes
perfect sense because Loki is going to
deal with time travel in different
universes
Kang's specialty and also the TVA has
fought Kang a few different times in the
comics as well they've never been able
to stop him though and then we have
Captain Marvel too which isn't
necessarily a part of phase 4 yet but
they haven't announced it to be in phase
5 as well so we'll put it with phase 4
because it's not coming to long after
but there's a report from Mikey Sutton
that rogue is going to be the main
villain of Captain Marvel - she is a
classic foe - Captain Marvel in the
comics and apparently the MCU is also
going to explore her relationship with
gambit so if rogue pops up in Captain
Marvel - gambit might as well and if he
doesn't in Captain Marvel - he probably
will not too long after then we have the
Hawkeye series who of course is going to
bring Kate Bishop to the MCU she will
assume the new role of Hawkeye but that
may not be all because the character
Firestar has been reported to be coming
to the MCU and a lot of people think
that she could make an appearance in the
Hawkeye series and then we have another
movie that's not necessarily phase 4 but
hasn't exactly been announced for phase
5 yet but we have a release date and
it's not coming to long after phase 4 so
we'll include it and that is black
panther 2 now we have a couple of big
reports here one of course being that
Namor will make his Marvel Cinematic
Universe debut in black panther 2 and
given his connection to Wakanda from the
comics and the conflict that they
typically have with each other this just
makes perfect sense not to mention there
has been a few Namor Easter eggs in the
MCU but then we got another interesting
report a report from the Twitter account
Rodger at Ward L said that Wolverine is
going to get his combat Nanosuit thanks
to Shuri and Aunt Arctic vibranium
implying that Wolverine could start to
be referenced in the MCU as early on as
black panther - although I don't think
he'll make his debut in black panther 2
but then we have for love
and thunder where we'll be getting Jane
Foster as Thor and of course this was
confirmed at San Diego comic-con lady
Thor is coming and a lot of people seem
to think that the main villain that
Christian Bale is going to be playing is
gore the god butcher but that is not
confirmed yet another rumor is that
Taika Waititi has been teasing the
silver surfer to appear in Thor love and
thunder as well we know that Thor 11
Thunder is going to explore the cosmic
side of the MCU and we know that
Galactus is eventually going to be the
main big bad of the MCU as well so the
silver surfer will be arriving
eventually and a lot of people think
that Taika Waititi has actually teased
this recently and then we have Nova now
Nova was actually supposed to be in
Avengers infinity war instead of
foretelling the guardians of the galaxy
that fan owes decimated Xander they were
actually going to show that scene and in
that scene we would have saw Nova get
sent to earth to warn the Avengers about
Thanos not the Hulk now unfortunately
that scene was cut but Kevin Feige has
stated many times that Nova is coming to
the MCU at some point and it's widely
speculated that Nova will make his MCU
debut and guardians of the galaxy vol 3
and unfortunately we don't really know
which phase guardians 3 is going to be
in yet but here's hoping that we see
Nova in phase 4 now of course we did
have some other shows officially
announced by Marvel one of those being
Moon Knight which could have a bigger
connection to the MCU than you might
think it looks like the midnight sons
are going to be coming to the MCU and
that team consists of Doctor Strange
Ghost Rider Moon Knight and blade now
blade isn't phase 4 but he will be
coming not too long after phase 4 and
hopefully in phase 5 we get a midnight
son's team then of course we had
she-hulk announced for Disney plus the
character Jennifer Walters will be
making her MCU debut and then we will
officially have to hoax in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and last but
definitely not least Kamala Khan is
coming to the MCU as Marvel has already
announced a Miss Marvel Disney Plus show
and it's actually rumored that with her
could come a very weird inclusion of the
Inhumans according to a rumor the
Inhumans will be a TV show that is
constantly going to be playing in the
back
of Miss Marvel which is kind of an odd
thing to do but if that is a part of
Marvel's plans that kind of means
they're in the MCU even if it is as a TV
show so that's a list of all the
characters who are rumored and confirmed
to be coming in phase four of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe which one of these
characters are you most excited to see
in phase four and have you heard any
rumors about any other different
characters that could possibly come and
phase four as well so let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the MCU for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof